la situation
la situation n'est pas la même
que celle qu'on pouvait avoir encore il
y a trois ou quatre ans concernant les
jeux d'argent et de hasard ou il y avait
bien sûr des phénomènes d'addiction mais
c'est phénomènes d'addiction restaient
encore
je dirais des phénomènes individuels
des personnes qui tombaient dans
l'addiction là la difficulté que nous
avons c'est que nous avons un écosystème
industriel qui s'est mis en place qui
est très efficace et qui
utilise toutes les technologies de
captation de l'attention qui sont les
technologies de base de l'économie
numérique pour vendre
et proposer des jeux d'argent au public
donc les études que nous avons sont des
études qui montrent que il y a la
dernière étude de l'OFDT dit qu'il y a
1,4 millions de personnes qui sont
susceptibles d'être joueur problématique
ça correspond à 6% des joueurs en
général mais on considère que en pari
sportifs c'est plutôt 18% des joueurs de
paris sportifs et là nous avons une
dernière étude qui vient de sortir on a
malheureusement pas la même étude
actualisée que celle de l'OFDT de 2019
nous l'aurons l'année prochaine mais il
y a une étude qui vient de sortir qui
est une étude qui a été faite à partir
d'un panel de joueurs online mais qui
joue à tout type de jeu y compris des
jeux îles légaux donc on sait que
l'addiction enfin le taux de prévalence
sur les jeux illégaux les casinos en
ligne etc et beaucoup plus important
mais les taux de prévalence sont des
taux qui sont beaucoup plus proches de
20%
que même de 16 ou de 18%. donc on a un
certain nombre d'indications qui
montrent que les taux de prévalence
augmentent et nous nous avons d'ailleurs
un capteur qui est le fichier des auto
interdits puisque nous gérons maintenant
à la suite du ministère de l'Intérieur
le fichier des auto interdits nous avons
aujourd'hui 80 demandes par jour
d'interdiction d'auto interdiction
volontaire vous savez c'est
l'interdiction vous êtes interdit
pendant trois ans là où on avait
auparavant une vingtaine de dossiers par
jour donc on voit bien que le phénomène
a changé je dirais de dimensions